Dr excuse-moi mais il y a a une collab à
faire appelez-vous je sais pas
contactez-vous salut c'est sherine
Boutella et j'interprète Jessica Carson
dans PAM et la rose salut c'est evic et
qui est Mister VI et qui est ça tu feras
un blooper tu feras une compile salut
c'est EV qui est Mister VI et qui est
Sacha ch dans Pamel rose la série sur
Canal
ouais premier coup du premier
coup si ça doit pitcher la série c'est
une enquête policière qui son autour
d'un meurtre d'une suite de meurtrre sur
des youtubeurs et nous avons deux
enquêteurs du coup qui bah qui mèent
l'enquête Richard bulit et Douglas
reiper interprêté par Cadeo qui sont
donc des agents du FBI qui sont un peu
sur la fin et cette affaire va leur
servir que de dernière pierre à laquelle
se raccrocher mais imaginez un mur
d'escalade tu vas enc tomber et te reste
qu'un galet au mur auquel t'accroché bah
c'est
celui-là je suis sûr que vous pensez
exactement ce que je pense non et donc
voilà on verra ce qui va se passer pour
eux mais en tout cas c'est le pitch du
début super pitch ch Jessica Carson
c'est la nouvelle du FBI totalement à
l'opposé pour le coup de kdo de Bullit
riper très ambitieuse très carré très
smart très logique blasé quoi d'avoir
ces deux boulets alors que elle elle
rêve d'avoir une carrière dans le FBI et
qu'elle est vachement sûr d'elle et
qu'elle sait qu'elle a des capacités et
que il y a ces deux mecs là en fait qui
font n'importe quoiouve la seule femme
aussi dans univ la seule femme
évidemment assez assez macho il ne
faudra surtout rien dire même sous la
torture je sais comment tu t'appelles
bastarde il a il y a un lien particulier
avec donut donc le chef le responsable
où elle l'utilise finalement et elle
utilise ce côté un peu très Patriarca de
ce mec là qui pense qu'il peut tout lui
apprendre je suis un atout tout court
come vous voulez MAE ma quoi et au final
elle utilise ça pour le manipuler et
utiliser en fait tous les mecs qui a
autour d'elle c'est pour les réseaux
sociaux ils vont jamais garder tout ta
réponse c'est trop long ils vont jamais
tout
zit le gars qui met un quart d'heure
pour répondre à chaque question bien sûr
bien sûr non mais mais ouais donc en
fait elle a elle a réussi à utiliser
tout ça à son avantage et et j'adore
j'ai adoré jouer ce personnage après le
seul truc je continue fait tu peux
partir si tu veux menteur je te on se
voit mais c'est bien comme ça ils ont du
contenu ils comprend ce qu'ils veulent
tu sais comment ça marche non je sais
qu'il appuie sur l R et Sacha ch qui est
tout simplement un youtubeur qui a pour
direction artistique de recréer des
films entier à l'aide de fruits et
légumes doc on arrive bientôt attends tu
trouves que je vais pas vite si tu veux
je peux appuyer sur le champignon ah
merde les champignons c'est assez
atypique mais il y a une communauté qui
suit derrière parce qu'il a plusieurs
millions d'abonnés mon manque de courage
va faire que je vais à un moment
mal'aliier au FBI pour les aider à mener
à bien cette enquête c'était s Sacho et
gardz la pêche c'est ce film là c'est le
me rose le premier qui m'a mis à
l'humour moi je suis le plus grand fan
de Cadeo qui existe sur terre la grosse
émission tout ce qu'ils ont fait
avant les anthotologies tout ça je suis
gros peut-être un des plus grands fans
de France CAD moi cétait sur le tourage
du flambeau il me dit on fait la série
Pamel la rose moi je lui dis est-ce que
je peux jouer un
buisson il me dit bah j'ai peut-être
mieux j'ai peut-être des du texte avec
et tout donc incroyable quand je vois
que le rôle est golerie qu'il est en
plus du bon côté dans le sens où je suis
un allié de Bullit riper bah c'est c'est
moi les premières scènes que j'ai joué
l'impression d'être dans un rêve et là
je me disis c'est marrant le rêve est
réel et donc c'est vraiment pour le coup
moi un un vrai rêve de gosse je dis pas
ça pour les caméra c'est vrai c'est
vraiment mon film de jeev je peux
retrouver je peux retrouver plein j'ai
mes premiers crétrages que je faisais
quand j'étais petit avec le camescope de
mon père je
repreneaz des noms qu' avait dedans mais
tu pe la rose moi je ferais pas mieux je
suis clairement pas aussi fan mais
j'étais très fan aussi de Cadeo des des
des Kat pamé la rose donc quand j'ai
quand mon agent m'a prop proposais de
passer ce casting là je suis arrivée
j'étais comme ça laamb qui tremblait
j'étais hyper impressionné puis j'ai
fait les essais avec eux où en fait on
fait on fait le texte avec eux j'étais
hyper intimidée mais je je voulais
tellement ce rôle que je je me donnais à
fond pour essayer de paraître normal et
chill et cool et à la fin en partant je
leur ai dit les gars genre même si je
suis pas prise pour ce rôle c'était
juste un bonheur et un honneur fou de
passer cette heure avec vous et de et de
et et d'échanger et faire cette scène et
surtout quand il m'a fait le que en vrai
que
ain il est là c'est vraiment ça donc un
petit coup de pression même le premier
jour de tournage quand j'étais avec eu
j'étais hyper stressé hyper j'avis envie
de les impressionner en fait tu sais tu
as envie de d'être à la hauteur j'ai
raté ma première prise comme ça j'ai
raté ma première prise parce que je
c'était à
toiic grave oui pardon parce que pour
moi j'étais en spectateur et c'est très
très dur sur les premières de se lancer
parce que tu te dis ok mince c'est pas
un rêve en fait c'est vraiment la vité
donc et puis la première impro aussi tu
as envie de ouais tu bide en fait tu
veux les faire rire B ouais tu veux les
faire rire tu veux tester un truc tu ve
te marrer et tu dis ah ça c'est c'est
les c'est les goats et tu peux pas comme
ça te permettre de bon au bout d'un
moment tu en fais et tu vois que ça
marche c'est cool mais il te mettent
assez vite à l'aise j'allis dire en
parallèle vraiment ils sont trop trop
cool ils sont tellement bienveillants
ils sont ils font tout pour te
t'intégrer te faire sentir à l'aise et
donc ça te met ça ça tout de suite tu
sais tu es à la maison quoi tout que moi
j'étais toute gamine quand je regardais
ça
quoi encore plus jeune moi j'étais
encore plus jeune moi j'avais au moins
TR 4 ans pourquoi tu penses que j'ai
quel âge je sais pas plus que moi moi je
suis tellement jeune j'ai 30 ans tu es
plus jeune j'en ai 30 ans bah ok ah ok
ouais B pareil j'avais le même âge en
moins de 3 ans je TikTok ça me connaît
et je veux une identité temporaire Elvis
prley me c'est cool ça je connais
absolument rien d'Elvis en réalité et je
me suis même pas préparé du tout à faire
Elvis parce que je pense que c'est ouais
mais je pense que c'est ça qui fait
aussi le le comic de la
situation et c'est Olivier exactement
qui m'a dit en fait
FA et il dansait avec mais moi j'avais
jamais réellement connu c'est pas du
tout ma génération je vous rappelle que
je suis un V
encore non et depuis peu je suis plus et
non non le Elvis finalement était pas du
tout une mais le créer un mauvais ELV
c'était plus ça me faisait plus marrer
justement de pas avoir de connaissance
CLA pour justement pouvoir créer un
personnage un peu immonde qui se veut
ressembler à mais qui n'est pas du tout
qui justement crée le côté décalé c'éit
très très très très très très drôle céit
notre première scène ensemble
d'ailleurs dans le bureau de Bull riper
où il a fait justement se déancher j'en
pouvais plus CIT très très très très
drôle c'est pas évident parce que
c'était à ce momentl justement quand on
devit je faisais la scène de fin et je
vous regardais dans les yeux je me
rappelle et vous étiez comme ça pas
filmé mais vous deviez rester sérieux et
et j'ai vu bah tout le monde se marrer
donc à ce momentlà ça m'a détendu c'est
à ce moment-là d'ailleurs je me suis
détendu ouais ben j'ai dit ah c'est bon
on je fais partie du de l'équipe je suis
pas juste un invité surprise on a un tu
à arrêté et la route à prendre et est-ce
qu'on prendrait pas la route de
Memphis on y va si tu pouvais avoir
l'identité de la personnalité de ton
choix laquelle serait-elle Stevie du
loft 1 AFFID Turner moi oh ouais ah
ouais ok mais galerie de ouf énorme
maisveilleux tu l'as tout tout toute la
vie ou vraiment non non non une petite
une petite un petit weekend ok ah quand
même ouais ok le temps d'aller au resto
aller en boîte faire un
show répondre quelques commentaires sur
un stade de clocharda et pu trop c'est
ça insulter de trois personnes en story
oui mais non mais elle a elle elle a un
répondant de ouf oui c'est vrai ah ouais
je dirais Drake dans dans la longévité
de carrière et dans la l'évolution de
carrière qu'il a eu le l'aspect mental
làdedans par qu' VI d'une série quand
même pour ado et qu'il a réussi à créer
un empire comme ça j'aimerais juste
savoir ce qu'il y a dans sa tête et et
comment tu réussis d'année en année à je
CIS que tu all me suivre mon second
degré ok j'aimerais cher une bouteill
boute déjà ça se
prononce
américain tu feras un blooper tu feras
une compile salut c'estic et qui est
Mister V et qui est
ça Sacha Sacha mais je connais pas le
nom de famille Sacha ch chaud ok yo
c'est Mister VI IIC non c'est l'inverse
ok on recommence yo c'est IIC et Mister
V et Sacha ah j'ai un truc dans la gorge
merde salut c'est Ivic
sach exactement salut c'est qui est
Mister V qui est Sacha show dans Pamel
rose la série sur Canal let's
[Musique]
go
y